.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER NOW.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
TUCKER, AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
WE BEGIN THIS NIGHT WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT, THE DISGRACED
FORMER GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK,
ANDREW CUOMO, HAS NOW OFFICIALLY
BEEN CHARGED WITH GROPING A
FORMER AIDE, WHICH IF CONVICTED
COULD LAND CUOMO ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
WE HAVE ALL THE DETAILS COMING
UP.
ALSO, A JUDGE IS NOW REFUSING TO
PAUSE NEW YORK CITY'S VACCINE
MANDATE FOR CITY EMPLOYEES, AND
NOW THE FDNY IN NEW YORK IS
PREPARING TO CLOSE 20% OF ALL
FIRE DEPARTMENT COMPANIES IN THE
CITY AND TAKE 20% OF ALL
AMBULANCES OFF-LINE AS THE
MANDATES NOW ARE SET TO TAKE
EFFECT ON MONDAY.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
THE NYPD ALSO BRACING FOR A
MASSIVE STREET COP SHORTAGE.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THIS
STRAIGHT AHEAD TONIGHT.
THE IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY, AND
WE WILL TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE ONGOING WORKER SHORTAGE,
AND OF COURSE, THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES WE HAVE HAD.
BUT FIRST, WE TURN ONCE AGAIN TO
THE ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF
AFGHANISTAN.
>> Announcer: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE, ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
DAY 75.
>> Sean: 88 DAYS SINCE
JOE BIDEN PROMISED HE WOULDN'T
DO IT, 75 DAYS SINCE HE HAS DONE
IT, ABANDONING HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS, THOUSANDS OF
GREEN CARD HOLDERS, OUR ALLIES,
OUR FRIENDS, THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS, ALL LEFT BEHIND ENEMY
LINES BY JOE BIDEN.
HE SIMPLY HAS TURNED THE PAGE,
AND TODAY, HE JUST JETS OFF TO
EUROPE, LEAVING BEHIND A TORRENT
OF SELF-INFLICTED CATASTROPHES.
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY.
IT IS AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER,
SLOWING DOWN TO ITS LOWEST
QUARTERLY GROWTH SINCE THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC.
THE BORDER AN ABSOLUTE
NIGHTMARE, ALSO.
ANOTHER MASSIVE CARAVAN IS ON
THE WAY, BUT INSTEAD OF FIXING
THIS CRISIS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE NOW
PLANNING TO GIVE -- GET THIS --
CERTAIN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS A
WHOPPING $450,000.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THIS IS NOT A JOKE, AS JOE LIKES
TO SAY, AND TONIGHT, JOE'S
PRECIOUS BUILD BACK BETTER NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST OF VISION
THE COUNTRY, IT IS STALLED IN
CONGRESS WITH SEEMINGLY NO WAY
OUT.
THERE IS NO RECONCILIATION GOING
ON, EVEN THOUGH BIDEN GAVE SUCH
AN IMPASSIONED FINAL PITCH
BEFORE LEAVING FOR EUROPE
EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THESE PLANS ARE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY ARE FULLY PAID FOR.
THEY DON'T ADD A SINGLE PENNY TO
THE DEFICIT.
THEY DON'T RAISE TAXES ON ANYONE
MAKING LESS THAN $400,000 A
YEAR.
I DON'T WANT TO PUNISH ANYONE'S
SUCCESS.
I AM A CAPITALIST.
I WANT EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO
COME IF THEY WANT TO BE A
MILLIONAIRE OR BILLIONAIRE, TO
BE ABLE TO SEEK THEIR GOALS.
BUT ALL I'M ASKING IS, PAY YOUR
FAIR SHARE.
PAY YOUR FAIR SHARE.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE "PAY YOUR
FAIR SHARE."
"PAY YOUR FAIR SHARE."
OKAY, IT IS GETTING BIZARRE.
AND THIS WHOLE -- I KNOW HE
STILL USES AN ABACUS, WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT IS ACTUALLY
CALLED A CALCULATOR, IT WORKS A
LITTLE BIT BETTER, AND YOU CAN'T
SAY TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SPENDING WON'T COST YOU
ANYTHING.
NOTHING.
KEEP IN MIND, DEMOCRATS HAVE
TRIED THIS BUILD BACK BETTER NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALISM, YOU KNOW,
LEGISLATION, IT FUNDS ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE HAVE THAT,
YOU KNOW, ROADS, BRIDGES,
TUNNELS, BETTER KNOWN AS THE FBI
F, AND THEY ARE NOW TO TRILLION
DOLLAR BILLS STALLED IN
CONGRESS.
GREAT JOB, JOE.
TONIGHT, THE SOCIALIST LEFT WING
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN'T
SEEM TO COME TO TERMS WITH HOW
MUCH OF YOUR MONEY THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEND AND HOW MUCH THEY
WANT TO TAX YOU.
THE LATEST DRAFT OF THE BUILD
BACK BETTER PROPOSAL COMES IN AT
A WHOPPING $1.7 TRILLION.
A LOT OF THAT IS SMOKE AND
MIRRORS BECAUSE THEY ONLY ARE
FUNDING X NUMBER OF YEARS WHEN
THEY REALLY INTEND TO DO IT FOR
TEN YEARS.
THE FAR LEFT BUZZWORD OF THE DAY
IS EQUITY.
IF IT MENTIONED 44 TIMES, AND TE
CLIMATE, THAT IS MENTIONED A
WHOPPING 110 TIMES, BUT IT IS
JUST NOT ENOUGH FOR THE
SOCIALISTS.
NO, THEY ARE NOW NINE SOLID NOSE
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
CONGRESSWOMAN CORI BUSH SAID SHE
FELT BAMBOOZLED.
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB REPORTEDLY
SCREECHED "HELL NO" AND THEN
STORMED OUT OF THE MEETING.
AOC IS NOW THREATENING TO VOTE
NO.
CONGRESSWOMAN JAYAPAL JUST TOLD
CONGRESS THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET THIS LEGISLATION
THROUGH THE HOUSE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, NANCY PELOSI IS
VERY NERVOUS.
DON'T EMBARRASS THE PRESIDENT.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A MINUTE.
BIDEN TOLD CONGRESS HE NEEDED
THIS AGREEMENT BEFORE HE JETTED
OFF TO EUROPE FOR THIS CLIMATE
SUMMIT.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NOW PELOSI REPORT OF WARNING
FELLOW DEMOCRATS NOT TO
EMBARRASS JOEY WHILE HE IS A
BROAD.
PRAISING JOE'S -- THIS IS MY
FAVORITE MOMENT OF THE DAY --
NANCY PELOSI, WHO STRUGGLES A
LITTLE BIT COGNITIVELY HERSELF,
NANCY PELOSI TALKING ABOUT, WOW,
HOW ENGAGED JOE IS AND HE WROTE
THE BILL AND HIS ENCYCLOPEDIC
KNOWLEDGE.
JOE BIDEN?
IS THIS THE SAME JOE BIDEN, WE
HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT, THAT ALL MEN AND
WOMEN ARE CREATED BY, OH, YOU
KNOW, OH, THE THING, THAT GUY?
ANYWAY, PELOSI WAS A NERVOUS
WRECK TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FOR THOSE WHO SAID I WANT TO
SEE TEXT, THE TEXT IS THERE FOR
YOU TO REVIEW, FOR YOU TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT, FOR YOU TO ADD
TO, OR SUBTRACT FROM, WHATEVER
IT IS.
WE HAVE AGREEMENT ON MOST OF
THOSE THINGS.
NOW WHEN PEOPLE SEE THE LANGUAGE
THEY MAY SAY THIS GOES FURTHER
THAN I THOUGHT, I DON'T KNOW.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THEY SAY BACK.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT WE
PLANNED FOR $3.5 TRILLION.
WE WERE TOTALLY READY, AND I SAY
THIS BECAUSE I FEEL SOME LEVEL
OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR WORKING
EVERYBODY SO HARD, TO BE ON TIME
FOR SEPTEMBER 15TH.
AND THEN, THE RUG WAS PULLED OUT
WHEN THEY SAID WE ARE NOT GOING
THAT HIGH, BUT IN THE MEANTIME,
THE CLOCK DID NOT STOP TAKING ON
THE CALENDAR.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THERE ARE
A FEW THINGS IN THE DRAFT TEXT
PELOSI IS REFERRING TO.
$100 BILLION UNIVERSAL CHILD
CARE, $20 BILLION CLIMATE
CHANGE, $10 BILLION FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINICS,
$9 BILLION PER MONTH THE
GOVERNMENT HANDOUTS TO FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN, $5 BILLION FOR
THE CDC, $5 BILLION FOR A FLEET
OF NEW ELECTRIC VEHICLES FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, FOR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR THE POST OFFICE,
AND WE CAN GO ON AND ON ALL
NIGHT.
THIS IS FAR FROM A DONE DEAL, SO
AS PELOSI LIKES TO SAY, THEY
WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO PASS THE
BILL BEFORE ANY OF US FIND OUT
WHAT IS ACTUALLY IN THE BILL.
IN FACT, EARLIER TODAY, PELOSI
WASN'T EXACTLY EAGER TO ANSWER
MANY QUESTIONS, LOOKING VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE AFTER THE DISASTER
WHICH IS NOT JOE BIDEN WAS
SQUASHED AGAIN BY THE LIBERAL
WING OF HIS PARTY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MADAME SPEAKER --
>> SIMPLE QUESTION, ARE YOU
HOLDING AN INFRASTRUCTURE VOTE
TODAY?
HAVE YOU MADE THAT DECISION?
ARE YOU HOLDING INFRASTRUCTURE
VOTE TODAY?
ARE YOU HOLDING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE -- ARE YOU
HOLDING --
>> Sean: OH, CLEARLY PELOSI
HAS A LOT ON HER MIND, NOT ONLY
DOES SHE NEED TO SECURE ENOUGH
VOTES IN THE HOUSE, WHICH SHE
HAS BEEN UNABLE TO DO.
ALSO, DEMOCRATS CAN'T AFFORD TO
LOSE ONE SINGLE VOTE IN THE U.S.
SENATE.
AND RIGHT NOW, WELL,
SENATOR MANCHIN, SENATOR SINEMA,
THEY ARE STILL UNDECIDED, AND
SOME ON THE HOUSE SIDE ARE
STARTING TO REVOLT.
ONE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN HAS
ALREADY CALLING FOR THE TWO
UNDECIDED SENATORS TO BE OUSTED
FROM THE PARTY, AND IN THE
COMING DAYS, WE WILL KNOW ONE
THING FOR SURE, IS AOC, IS THE
SQUAD ALL TALK AND NO ACTION, IN
OTHER WORDS, ARE THEY REALLY
JUST SWAMP CREATURES ALREADY TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.?
THERE TO GET ALONG BECAUSE THEY
LIKE TO BE CALLED CONGRESSWOMAN
OR SENATOR, WHATEVER THEY HAPPEN
TO BE, OR ACTUALLY SOCIALIST,
WITH A BACKBONE, AND IDEOLOGY,
ARE THEY WILLING TO FIGHT FOR
THE THINGS THEY SAID THEY ARE
GOING TO FIGHT FOR?
THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING AS IT ALL UNFOLDS,
BUT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, THE
GOOD OF THE COUNTRY, WELL, BUILD
BACK BETTER SHOULD NEVER SEE THE
LIGHT OF DAY.
IT IS AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
CAPITALISM, THE GREATEST WEALTH
PRODUCING SYSTEM EFFORT DESIGNED
BY MANKIND, THAT'S RIGHT, YOU
GET LIFE, LIBERTY, THE PURSUIT
OF HAPPINESS, THANK GOD WE GET
ALL OF THESE RIGHTS FROM OH, YOU
KNOW, THE THING, THAT THING,
GOD, THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING,
AND DOWN BY OUR CREATOR, IF YOU
THINK SUPPLY SHORTAGES, LABOR
SHORTAGES, INFLATION IS BAD NOW,
YOU WAIT UNTIL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPENDS ANOTHER
$2 TRILLION ON THEIR BIG
GOVERNMENT WOMB TO THE TOMB,
CRADLE TO GRAVE SOCIALISM.
ADD TO THAT THE ONGOING VACCINE
MANDATES, THIS IS NOW ABOUT TO
HIT FULL FORCE, AND NOW
THOUSANDS OF NURSES AND COPS AND
PARAMEDICS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL AND FIREMEN, EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS, THEY ARE ALL GOING
TO BE OUT OF WORK.
NOW IT IS NOT A MATTER OF VAX OR
DON'T VAX, THEY HAVE DECIDED FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEY ARE WILLING
TO GIVE UP THEIR SALARY,
BENEFITS, AND PENSION BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE IN THEIR DECISION.
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT,
SEEMS LIKE THEY MADE UP THEIR
MIND.
IN NEW YORK CITY ALONE COME UP
TO 40% OF POLICE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS MIGHT BE OUT OF A
JOB AS SOON AS MONDAY.
THAT WILL BE AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER FOR THE CITY OF
NEW YORK.
ANYONE ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS
GOING TO MAKE NEW YORK MORE
SAFE, MORE SECURE?
ANYONE THINK THIS WILL MAKE
AMERICA A BETTER PLACE?
OF COURSE NOT.
THIS WILL BE BAD.
AND ACCORDING TO BIDEN'S OWN
CHIEF PROPAGANDIST, JEN CIRCLED
BACK PSAKI, OUR WOES HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH BIDEN'S
POLICIES, AND SAID ACCORDING TO
PSAKI, THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS,
YOU AMERICANS, IT IS YOUR FAULT,
IT IS
WHAT SHE SAID, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
AMERICANS WHO ARE SO, SO WORRIED
ABOUT GETTING THEIR CHRISTMAS
GIFTS ON TIME, HALLOWEEN, IS
THIS GOING TO BE HAPPENING?
>> WELL, SO MANY PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE PURCHASING MORE
GOODS ONLINE.
MAY BE SOME OF IT IS FROM HABITS
THAT DEVELOPED DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WHEN PEOPLE WEREN'T
LEAVING THEIR HOME.
SOME OF IT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT
HAS BEEN UNDERWAY FOR THE LAST
NINE MONTHS, WHERE 5 MILLION
MORE PEOPLE ARE WORKING, ON A
CLAIMANT RATE CUT IN HALF,
LEADING TO A MASSIVE INCREASE IN
VOLUME.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING AT
PORTS.
WE ARE ADDRESSING AND ATTACKING
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES, EVEN
WITH THE INCREASED VOLUME, WHICH
IS THE ROOT CAUSE HERE.
>> Sean: JEN, THAT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IS STALLED.
INFLATION IS HERE TO STAY.
TALK TO LAWRENCE SUMMERS, MAYBE
HE CAN HELP EDUCATE YOU.
JUST TO RECAP, IN THE WACKY
WORLD OF BIDEN, YOUR ONLINE
SHOPPING HABITS, THAT IS WHAT IS
CAUSING THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
BUILD BACK BETTER COSTS NOTHING.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT.
WE ARE REALLY SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN, THE
COGNITIVE MESS THAT HE IS, HAS
ENCYCLOPEDIC KNOWLEDGE ON
ANYTHING?
I DON'T EVEN THINK HE KNOWS WHAT
DAY OF THE WEEK IT IS.
THE WORLD IS GOING TO END IN TEN
YEARS BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
RIGHT NOW FOR NANCY PELOSI IS
THAT NO ONE EMBARRASSED JOE
WHILE HE IS OUT ABROA